this title was first announced I thought
it was going to be a rogue squadron
movie it's not but I'll still take it
rogue one a Star Wars story first
trailer has hit what did I think I'm
pretty intrigued by this thing this is
still clocking as one of my most
anticipated movies of the year and it
was before I even saw this trailer I
like the whole concept of sort of this
lateral fleshing out of the star wars
universe because as much as I think it
is at this point appropriate that the
Star Wars series itself centers on you
know these string of characters that the
the sky walker family factors it in some
way in the form of Anakin or Leia or
Luke or now we've got neo kylo Ren and
so I get all that but the universe of
Star Wars is so much bigger than that
it's got to be bigger than the sky
walker so to see a story that they are
not involved in I'm yes I understand
it's rumored that Darth Vader will
appear in some fashion but regardless
they are not the focus it's not about
them I like that I love the whole vibe
of the thing I like the tone that
they've got playing with the theme music
because again obviously very much Star
Wars music oh with a different tone a
different feel and I like it overall
because the overall vibe is different
from Star Wars and I like that in this
case cuz it's not part of the main
series I want the main series to feel
Star Wars these side stories these star
wars stories as they're calling them I
want to feel different but just be in
that same universe so I want something
that is more of a Dirty Dozen war movie
I want something with that feel but with
lasers and 80 80 s and the Death Star
and that looks like pretty much what
this is so I like the vibe I like the
feel I love this cast that said there
isn't much about the sort of bits we see
of the cast that really stands out too
much except for C Mon Mothma which I
loved and gave me a huge grin but that
that's my nostalgia that's because I
recognize that character she doesn't
actually do much in the trailer I I
admit that as this trailer seems to
frame it we have a clear lead in the
form of this female character
Felicity Jones is playing now most of
what I'd heard up to this point
indicated more of an ensemble piece
whereas the trailers framed it much more
as being her story and if it is in fact
more her story that does not interest me
as much me she seems find as a character
her lines are a little cheesy but most
Star Wars lines taken out of context can
be pretty cheesy let's not kid ourselves
but in any case I was more interested in
the group dynamic than I wasn't seeing
an individual story now that could just
be this trailer the film itself may in
fact be more of an ensemble overall
piece so I'm kind of reserving judgment
there but I will say if this ends up
just being her individual story that
doesn't interest me as much overall I
love the little glimpses and looks of
some of the villains stuff that we see
that just is what we're familiar with
but slightly off whoever the Admiral
isn't in the white I love the look at
him it's just stark and media like oh
that's serious there's a shot that no
idea what it is but there's a hooded
figure and there's Imperial Guards you
know what somebody for look at seen one
of these movies wizards this one are
some of those red Imperial Guards let me
see them do something I've been wanting
to see what these guys are made up since
they showed up in in Return of the Jedi
and we've never seen it please figure
out a way to have me see them do
something other than just stand there on
ceremony but there's that stuff there's
this glimpse of sort of this different
helmet different looking trooper maybe I
some sort of special unit no I don't
know but I'm really intrigued and over
all this it doesn't get me any more
excited than I already was cuz I'm still
kind of riding high coming off of the
force awakens but so this doesn't raise
my excitement level but it does sort of
keep that momentum going for me because
I just I like it I like that it's a
different vibe from what I would get
from a proper Star Wars entry but that
it is still clearly looking at it yeah
that's Star Wars I recognize that that
red alert sound from the Death Star and
there's the deaths are in their Star
Destroyers I know those blasters and I'm
just really intrigued to see how this
all pans out and I'm hoping it works
because I would like to see more stuff
like this in the future so that
my take on this trailer I was already on
board it doesn't give me too much that
you know I wouldn't have thought to see
but you know keeps my excitement going
and hopefully that'll hold through when
the thing actually comes out what about
you folks I'm assuming you've seen the
trailer by now as of the time of this
recording over 6 million people have so
what were your thoughts on it whatever
they were drop something down in the
comments and let's talk about it do not
forget to like or subscribe feel free to
follow me on twitter at council geeks
check out the council geeks podcast on
iTunes and stitcher and until next time
this council is adjourned